I'm police ashay we're now joined
remotely by the Bishop of Dover and the
former chaplain to the Speaker of the
House of Commons Rose Hudson Wilkins
thank you so much for being on the
program today how are you going to be
spending Easter Sunday this year very
different to normal I imagine very very
different indeed I've already taken part
in terms of listening and worshiping
with the archbishop on radio fourth
service and I will be touching in with
other services that are being
live-streamed in and around the diocese
as well today so staying at home that's
the important thing of course staying at
home today of course is a day where many
people would go to church and many
people would spend time with their
families with their loved ones and so
many of our viewers will be unable to do
that very difficult particularly for
those people who are on their own as
well this Easter Sunday what's your
message to them I think my message is
that Easter is about hope and it is
about joy and we should not forget the
joy of those who have survived the virus
including our prime minister the joy as
they leave hospitals and we see people
clapping and sharing and the faces of
those who are caring for them the hope
as well for us today that they the many
acts of kindness that we have seen that
those will continue beyond the corona
virus pandemic and in particular the way
in which we have seen perhaps for the
first time recognized that that our care
workers are cleaners our doctors our
nurses that they are right there on the
frontline and that they are key to the
life of the whole community
those are positive messages and I think
a final message that I would want to
share with everyone is to say please
let's remember that the tomb is empty
Jesus Christ is risen and the
resurrected Christ
comes to us in our homes he comes to us
on the hospital wards he comes to us in
the care rooms
he comes to us right where we are and he
ministers to us so please I know we are
missing our buildings but let's not get
a sort of edifice complex let's just
recognize that the risen Christ comes to
us where we are right there and so let
us acknowledge Christ in our homes let
us stay home protect the NHS and save
lives it's lovely to hear a bit of
positivity at a time that can seem very
bleak I wonder if for the church going
forward there may be new ways of doing
things you've seen more streaming for
example a ways of reaching out to people
in their homes do you think that the
church will change going forward I
sincerely hope that the church will
change you know for such a long time we
have gone into the building and we have
done our religious bit and then we go
away again and we don't do it until we
go back now we're recognizing that
actually that's just a building the
church is the people of God the body of
Christ and so I sincerely hope that one
of the changes we will see is people
actually living their faith in a real
practical upfront way and not hidden in
a building and I hope that as a church
those of us who are leaders within the
church both lay and ordained that we
will use all the various means possible
to equip our people to reach the people
of this land I am just so excited about
all the possibilities that lies ahead
talking about change and you are the
first female black bishop you're
ordained as a priest in 1994 just a
month after it was possible for women to
do so it feels that with every
modernization wave in the church you're
right on
crest of that wave do you feel that the
church still has further to go when it
comes to modernization oh I am sure I am
sure but you know it's it's it's very
difficult to change because very often
we don't look to the spirit we we look
to tradition and we we try to you know
what it is I think those in leadership
within the church and not just those in
leadership
you will hear ordinary congregation
members do they will say but this is the
way we've always done it but you know
what a joy when we are open to what the
Spirit is saying what God is saying to
us through the spirit it brings change
it sweeps through the land and I'm
excited about the possibilities to come
now when I was researching this
interview with you I read a very got a
call that you wrote in January and you
spoke about some people not accepting
your ministry you said when people
rejected me from doing their funerals
because I was black or because I was a
woman more so because I was black I
would allow myself to feel the pain of
that rejection because that pain is real
and there's no point in pretending it's
not now I have to say interview today
you seem like a immensely positive
individual but that must have been quite
difficult to deal with but but you know
that that's what Good Friday was about
Good Friday was about agony and pain and
we cannot skip that so when we
experience who are dying not only in
this country but throughout the world of
this virus we need to acknowledge pain
but we cannot dwell there we have to get
to Easter Sunday resurrection and so we
acknowledge the pain and we say thank
you God you're there with us in the pain
but you are there with us when we come
through that to the joy of Resurrection
and new life because that's what the
Easter is about it is about new life and
new beginnings thank you so much for
being on the program this morning ray is
hard
welcome there Happy Easter